alors on sait que c'est une soirée
spéciale pour tout le monde on veut que
tout le monde passe un bon moment et on
veut que moi je me sente en sécurité ça
c'est vraiment la priorité donc il y a
une politique très stricte si quelqu'un
ici combien un acte violent alors vous
recevrez l'Oscar du meilleur acteur et
ça vous change de voir des vrais genres
d'habitude j'ai dirigé un journal je
vais à ma disposition 130 personnes qui
passaient leur vie avoir des gens donc
j'ai eux me raconter tout donc je sais
plus de choses que vous mais
j'en suis convaincu Pascal tu gagnerais
être davantage connu par ta culture par
ton amour des livres et parce que tu
incarne vraiment sachez qu'on a eu une
équipe de crise s'il y a quelque chose
d'imprévisible ou de violent qui se
passe faites la même chose que la
dernière fois rien restez complètement
impassible et tout se passera bien vous
n'arrivez pas à dire je t'aime
c'est difficile c'est difficile de dire
je t'aime pourquoi voulez que je vous
dise je t'aime
[Rires]
ça veut dire tu m'appartiens et moi je
trouve que on doit pas sentir que
quelqu'un vous appartient il faut qu'on
sente que on doit se donner quoi merci
vous savez qu'on a une petite tradition
dans l'émission
de tirer un alors
le Zappy monsieur war comment ça va vous
venez de vous réveiller
[Rires]
Jean-Marie quelle plaie d'abord quel
plaisir
un bras d'honneur je rebondis Pascal
seriez-vous la caricature de vous-même
voilà
Kylian Mbappe point d'interrogation
ça parle beaucoup pour tout parfois pour
rien
on devrait parfois
freiner ralentir même créer un petit
hashtag ferme ta gueule ça ferait du
bien il y a deux photos noirs et blanc
c'est les plus jeunes
il y a des chances que ce soit vous la
deuxième connard
s
je voudrais bien mais il y a pas grand
chose à faire et à dire
ne vous inquiétez pas Sonia
effectivement je regarde ce qui se passe
à France Télévisions et je peux vous
dire que s'il y avait des choses à dire
sur France Télévision je le dirai et on
referme ces actualités avec ce sujet de
France 3 et cet étrange question posée
en début de reportage les gens se font
livrer n'importe quoi de nos jours
bonjour
c'est vous qui avez commandé un
kangourou alors moi non mais madame oui
les dérives que j'ai constaté dans les
entreprises sur lesquelles nous avons
enquêté ne se passe pas à France
Télévisions et j'en suis désolé pour
vous mais je vous fais parfaitement
confiance mais je dis qu'une enquête
indépendante vaudrait le coup et qui
pourrait confirmer vos dire ce soir et
ben elle est là et je suis pas sur le
service public moi je serai plus
intéressant que vous faisiez un cadeau
qu'on peut pas faire une émission
d'investigation chez vous mais bien sûr
que si mais j'aime bien que ce soit
puisque vous êtes la patronne de
l'investigation que vous le fassiez sur
Facebook
en fait j'ai perdu une dent juste avant
que les rapports et je suis pas bien
donc j'ai tapé vite fait sur le D non
mais faut rigoler ou quoi non je rigole
pas non vous avez perdu une dent pendant
l'édition ah ouais juste avant la
question là en fait non mais faut
rigoler elle est là votre dedans ou pas
vous êtes le premier candidat qui a
perdu une dent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça veut dire que le petit noir et
blanc là
oui c'est moi déjà j'étais beau et
qu'est-ce que vous avez dans les mains
là je pense le vibromasseur de ma mère
Fabrice est-ce que je peux récupérer
votre dent quand même parce qu'il y a
pas beaucoup d'animateurs pour récupérer
les dents de leurs candidats c'est
peut-être une dent qui vaut plus de 80
000 euros merci ah oui c'est vraiment
une dent d'accord ok ça va sinon ça va
dans la oui il y a pas dedans il y a
plus de dents du tout et on vient de le
voir face à vous les puissants perdent
leurs moyens est-ce qu'on peut dire que
vous êtes l'inverse du viagra
[Applaudissements]
mMED
[Musique]
Toulouse
la question si vous avez couché pour
réussir est-ce que c'est une réalité on
vous posez ce type de questions encore à
l'époque
c'était encore les années un peu voilà
enfin
il y avait un peu le côté Oran une
petite main par là c'est pas bien grave
je tiens pardon mais il y avait un peu
de ça on est dans les années où c'était
pas c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il y a
eu ce combat aussi de se dire bah non en
fait quand on parle de consentement
quand on parle de tout ça effectivement
mais ça ça quand même j'espère de plus
en plus évolué la naissance d'une petite
fille provoque des réactions plus
ambiguë
toi petite fille tu as détruit la vie de
ta maman
regarde comme elle est toute molle et
toute ripé elle est moche nous sommes
ici pour deux raisons d'abord rappeler
l'importance de mettre de la crème
hydratante tous les jours
[Rires]
quotidiennement et moi pas une seule
fois
c'était au standing elle est encore
sublime et moi je ressemble à une
vieille couille fripée est-ce que pour
être comédien et est-ce qu'il y a quand
même des similitudes je tire peut-être
un peu par les cheveux mais est-ce qu'il
y a des similitudes entre j'ai dit tirés
par les cheveux à côté de vous et je me
dis que c'est pas très faux
tout va bien petite mocheté ma petite
mocheté petite visqueuse
et on se retrouve très bientôt bonne
soirée amusez-vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]